♪ (intro music) ♪
With Flutter, removing
a widget completely is easy.
You just rebuild without it!
But what if you need
that widget to disappear
but still take up space?
So the rest of your layout
stays where it is,
the way iOS is hidden then,
Android's invisible work.
Try an Opacity widget!
Just wrap your widget with Opacity,
set the value to zero,
and you're all set!
You can also use Opacity for blending
one child of a stack onto another.
And if you want to animate
a changing Opacity,
there's an AnimatedOpacity widget too.
Just give an Opacity and a duration,
and when you rebuild,
it animates the change automatically.
For more info on Opacity
and all the other Flutter widgets,
hit the flutter.io
♪ (music) ♪